siamo arrivati al top penso del mio
canale youtube
immagino di questi più di questo non
possiamo arrivare ragazzi quindi oggi è
l'apice l'apice perché il signor rocco
rocco nazionale del rock
guardi italia ha reagito ad un mio
vecchio video del brano fa dove
raccontavo la mia prima volta e io non
posso che essere anzitutto onorato
perché vorrà
insomma il punto di riferimento insomma
per tutti quanti noi maschietti
vediamo se ci riusciamo a io non so
neanche come poer agita quella roba lì
io spero in modo positivo anche se di
positivo non c'era un cazzo troppo
curioso ragazzi siamo vedere video i
consigli di rocco per superare la prima
volta per famiglia e cominciamo ragazzo
oggi io volevo rendere omaggio al buon
rocco ringraziando innanzitutto per
avere agito mio video e già che ci sarà
vedere vero perché questo io avevo fatto
un video lui aveva reagito a quel vino
in una storia
io ho fatto questo di reazione al suo
video
lui ha reagito a questo video io adesso
sto reagendo alla sua reazione della
reazione a quel video dove lui era
bellissimo aiuto da un posto
meraviglioso scusa il ritardo
scusa ma sono stato molto impegnato tu
lo sai che faccio di lavoro lavoro molto
duro quindi abbiamo visto che rocco mi
se credo che non ci sia nient'altro da
aggiungere andiamo avanti ragazzi allora
ragazzi farlo anche un po tutti voi
perché coinvolgono prodotti che sta
facendo opportuna la cosa che mi fa
ridere che c'è rocco che sta ascoltando
quello che sta dicendo
mentre sto giocando al rocket league
broccoli bisogna prima volta come sapete
ormai già tutti non mi saltava quindi e
questo è stato un problema e non c'è
l'unico pensare troppo non va bene
ragazzi relax ribadisco questo concetto
quando voi pensate troppo il sangue al
cervello
bravo fa vigili bravo abbiamo studiato
il corpo umano sera il sangue si trova
nella zona del cervello non sta nel
piano sta nel uccelli marcovaldo verbi
baio ma cosa devo spirare più di questo
di traguardo comunque effettivamente con
cervello fa più vari ma uccello non deve
dire rocca 6 sicuramente più tenga il
mestiere che poi secondo me quando se
tutto sbloccato non è andata manco mai
però quello potrebbe giudicare solo il
nostro rocco vili se mandarmi il video
no ma noi non ce l'abbiamo registrato no
no ma anche quello dopo non ho mai
guarda grazie a dio da squalo ben beppe
volte sono andate bene però la
primissima ero ansioso perché volevo far
star bene il mio partner e quindi pensa
o rifare la super performance questo è
il problema da votano troppo ragazzino
quella non è stata l'unica volta è
successo un'altra volta
allora allora allora si rici divo se
recidivo ma lo so che cioè non è non è e
proprio ma io vi è venuta a milano per
uscire come lo sci hai detto milano
milano l'uso è venuta a casa mia
purtroppo non in tutti i sensi io ho
fatto un signore ho detto tu dormi nel
mio letto io dormo sul divano sono stati
a parlare poi leva nel letto io vado sul
divano a dormire quello sarebbe stato il
momento per prese fino qua il fatto
tutto perfettamente
red cro così poi gettarsi alle 3 di
notte nudo perfetto è il problema sta lì
in camera mia no ovviamente no però per
fare una cosa del genere cioè nel senso
almeno provare a dire ma se non ci ha
avuto le palle
nel senso che aironi che mi crogiolava
nel mio essere brava bla ma non può aver
sentito sta roba qua c'è la class
costruzione che ho visto nel gioco sui
dussel sedusse ti mette davanti a tre
quattro opzioni e tu scegli quella
giusta e bar antonella bianca è per
forza un sì
vai no non sono visto the peak sono un
deficiente un deficit non solo cita
dirle niente non abbiamo fatto niente ma
perché non hai fatto il sonnambulo cioè
che ti si è presentata da lei
direttamente mentre occhi chiusi su un
ambo le parti e così l'uccello a cannes
perché nella testa secondo me lei per
non farti male quindi per non crearsi lo
shock svegliarti secondo me te lo
schiavo
un giorno dopo si e ci siamo svegliati
fatto colazione e lei se ne torna e io
va associata mercure un mesetto dopo
method anche se lei voleva questa cosa
comunque ha raccolto il lato positivo
della serie questo cane dove il positivo
non c'è star all stars che fosse stata
io l'ultima volta ha avuto quest'ansia
giorno sarò questa grande a reazione
della reazione ma l'ultima volta che ho
avuto questa acqua quando stava scuola
alcol durante l'interrogazione c'era la
prof che mi controllava la verifica
capito è uguale cioè io so di avere
fatto schifo in certi ambiti quindi non
posso sapere che tu stai per ascoltare
ste robe perché mi stringe la solo
capito che l'anno dopo invece
giustapposto giorno soprattutto a posto
o imitato anche furono sono andata bene
poi tutte le altre volte nata benissimo
magari sera volevo farlo splendido la
domanda che pongo a rocco vai vai
ragazze c'è nel senso come fa come si fa
a sgomberare la mente va male da
incontrare influire insomma vj che detti
è semplice risposte talmente semplice
però è molto complicata perché non sei
l'unico
ok ragazzi alla tua età questo problema
meno anche io ci credo signori signori
meno male
meno male è un po come se la verifica di
matematica che ho portato al professore
che ha detto guarda fai schifo ma stai
tranquillo perché ai tempi
anch'io prendevo due in matematica a
posto a posto questo lo vada ti amiamo
cioè questo non lo dico a mia ma però
quello di una tattica non me l'ha mai
detto
amo lo stress da soli facciamo tutti in
automatico ero hai detto tu prima però
come devo fare come devo fà ci penso
troppo bravo problema è proprio questo
perché ci pensi così tanto
e tu hai detto anche la soluzione senza
volerlo la seconda volta è andata meglio
perché perché già la conosce v
quindi come devo fare il sangue a
rimandarlo juke è facile e naturale
pensare cervello dove andare in stand by
divertirsi
però un po arriva il fan senza
stressarlo perché
ogni pensiero del sangue su e meno giu
indirettamente funziona proprio così non
sta della struttura del cervello come mi
devo comportare devo fare la performance
la mia vita
ci tengo a lei deve assolutamente fargli
vedere quanto sono figo è l'opposto
relax confidence voi mi direte tu mi
dirai rockol confidence il cazzo cioè tu
lo fai sempre più di meno faccio due
piccolissime parentesi la prima è che è
tremendamente interessante tutto questo
perché mi ci ritrovo tantissimo sei
veramente un guru mamma mia dammi dati
di fatturazione e stimate come
consulenza ad enti parco è incredibile è
la seconda piccolissima parentesi e che
mi piace proprio come pronuncia anche
solo la parola cazzo ci dice dai in
senso proprio di potenza poi come quando
goku fa londinese uguale non so perché
non c'entra una sega sta parentesi però
ci tenevo a farlo mi emoziona sentirlo
parlare
andiamo avanti devi veramente ma
sinceramente lo dico fra il jazz e devi
rilassare e devi assolutamente pensare
creativa è una tua amica ma chi siete
amici che chiamate a scovarli che sa die
la scopa amica con la scopa mikami
castelli ogni volta a diventare matto le
migliori chiamate sono con la toccata e
fuga
la sposa mica perché è perché è tutto
più relax
non c'è coinvolgimento tra virgolette
sentimentale da quel punto di vista che
è quindi mi raccomando la ricordati se
riassumo e la ragazza la conoscevi già
appena conosciuta ma già la conosce vie
di port al relax totale seconda seconda
situation abbassa i livelli di dren
alina con l'esperienza lo riuscire a
fare in maniera impeccabile perché se tu
che controlli il tuo corpo e il tuo
uccello questo ci vuole un po di
esperienza c'è un po di tecnica ma è
facile non è
non è complicato adesso però tu
insegnami qualcosa anche tu dai voglio
che tu mi insegni a me a giocare ai
videogame è importante non ci capisco un
cazzo
mentre gioco vedere la nausea il vomito
come cazzo devo fare lo spieghi per
poter videogiocare insomma c'è bisogna
innanzitutto del joystick
ma forse sarebbe meglio iniziare da un
qualcosa di più familiare ecco tipo
questa è la stessa cosa
questo serve nei giochi dove piloti però
avremo modo di secondo me rischio questa
roba
magari vengo vengo io non mi muovo verso
le tue zone per farti capire come
utilizzare queste queste apparecchiature
insomma c'è un po di un po uno scambio
di informazioni devi parleremo ne
riparleremo intanto ti ringrazio perché
sei stato supergentile sono veramente
onorato a partire sia finito sto video
sono onorato di tutto questo mi dispiace
per la luminosità faceva schifo però
ragazzi questi giorni così come si dice
non mi piace anche vari social che mm
tedeschi xia le si chiede come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video è da ragazzi
[Musica]